[Music]
one of the most important themes and
plot drivers in ursula k leguins novel
the wizard of earthsea
is ged's interactions with what's
referred to
as the shadow or
his shadow and these are almost
completely antagonistic
until the
very end he fears he's angered by he
flees he fights this shadow
and it's only at the very end that
there's some sort of reconciliation with
his being that he brought into earthsea
inadvertently
and one of the key things that comes up
early on is this question does the
shadow
actually
have a name and the mages disagree about
it the summoner says i don't actually
know
ogean asserts that it does have a name
all things have a name
the arc mage genter says no it doesn't
have a name it's from a place where
names don't exist
and there's offers of aid from we could
call them bad actors in some some
respect to give ged the name of the
shadow which would give him power over
it from the dragon of pandora and from
the pteranodon the stone that that is an
old power of earth well it's not really
the stone itself but rather it's
representatives who say that it could
give him the name and we never really
find out until the very end
what its name is we'll talk about that
in a moment i do want to say something
before we go any deeper into this
because people are liable to bring this
up as soon as they hear the term the
shadow if they've heard anything
about the psychoanalyst jung they say
aha she must have gotten that from jung
ursula k le guin was crystal clear in
interviews that she did not get it from
jung she read the young stuff about the
shadow after wizard of earthsea
was published and so there's no direct
connection
there
this is important in part because of
what goes on
later in the story that a lot of people
want to read things in
so one of the questions we should begin
with is well what sort of thing
is this and you know get does his
research as leguin tells us and there's
not an awful lot of information to come
across there's just you know hints here
and there we get a interesting
discussion of it coming up in chapter
six when
get is trying to get back to rock and he
can't because the
wind turns him away because he he would
be bringing some evil
and he he's thinking about this he says
that thing was bottleless blind to
sunlight the creature of lightless
placeless timeless realm it must grope
after him through the days and across
the seas of the sunlit world and could
take visible shape only in dream and
darkness
it has as yet no substance or being that
the light of the sun would shine on and
so it is sung and the deed of hood
daybreak makes all earth and sea from
shadow brings forth form driving dream
to the dark kingdom
so that's you know a bit about its
ontological status it's it's being we
could say
here's something else
if once the shadow caught up with gad
it could draw his power out of him and
take from him the very weight
and warmth and life of his body and the
will that moved him so this is what the
shadow
desires what the shadow seeks it's
parasitical
upon being this is something similar to
the notion of evil as privation but not
complete non-being that we see in in
many thinkers particularly neo-platonist
thinkers what are its powers it can suck
the life out of get it can turn him
inside out turn him
into a gabeth as we find it doing to
somebody else
so the shadow is pursuing
ged and he is fleeing from it he is
running away and he's asking where can i
actually go that this thing won't be
able to
track me down
first he tries to go to rope that's not
an option anymore
then he is told that he should go to
uh
further north and go to oskill because
maybe somebody can help him there so he
he gets on a boat and they're all you
know
slaves or free people rowing the boat
and one of the men
says are you a slave or an oath breaker
neither why no knife then afraid to
fight said the man ski or jeering no
your little dog fight for you otak said
another who listened no dog that is otak
then he said something in oskillian that
made skier scowl and turn away here's
where we get to something important just
as he turned ged saw a change in his
face a slurring and shifting of his
features as if for a moment something
had changed him used him looking out his
eyes side long at get
so
skewer is actually going to be
used by the shadow the shadow is
following god on the same ship
and when they get get to oscillate skier
says i can lead you to the court of the
pteranodon i can lead you to this place
i'll take you along and ged says well
i don't like this guy
but i don't speak the language
so maybe this would be
a good idea and he asked him over and
over again how far skier turned his head
says not far
and
a little bit later
ged says darkness comes in snow how far
ski or
after a pause the other answered without
turning not far but his voice sounded
not like a man's voice but like a beast
horse and lipless that tries to speak
what we have there is the shadow in the
body of skewer it has taken over his
body his mind his soul his will
and now we have a confrontation
the shadow once again goes after ged and
it does so at the very start
by using ged's true name
before ged could speak spell or someone
power the gebbeth spoke saying in its
hoarse voice ged then the young man
could work no transformation but was
locked in his true being and must face
the gebbeth thus defenseless nor could
he summon any help in this alien land he
stood alone with nothing between him and
his enemy but the staff of you would in
his right hand the thing that had
devoured skior's mind and possessed his
flesh made the body take a step towards
ged a rage of horror filled get and he
swung up and brought his staff whistling
down on the hood that hid the shadow
face who didn't cloak collapse down
nearly to the ground under that fierce
blow
the body of a gabeth has been drained of
true substance into something like a
shell or a vapor in the form of man and
unreal flesh clothing the shadow which
is real the real person has been turned
into
a shell or a shadow the shadow is what
is real and it's going after ged he
manages to escape and to make it into
the court of the
terra nun
other adventures ensue there as i
mentioned the stone is is wanting to
take him as a slave and he escapes he
escapes in the form
of a bird and he flies all the way to
gant
uh to meet up with ogian
um ojin is able to transform him back
into
a human being and i i think it's worth
noting this line
get it taken hawk shape in fierce
distress and rage and when he flew from
oskill there had been one
thought in his mind to outfly both stone
and shadow to escape the cold
treacherous lands to go home the falcons
anger and wildness were like his own and
had become his own in his will to fly it
becomes the falcon's will
so
ojin transforms him back and ged says
listen i'm not looking for refuge here
i'm looking for counsel
can you help me out here
an ogian tells him something very
important after he tells them that the
shadow must have a name
he also says
dead says if the shadow has a name i
don't think it will stop and tell it to
me
ojin says no nor have you stopped and
told that your name and yet it knew it
on the moors of oscar it called you by
your name the name i gave you it's
strange how how does
the shadow know
god's name and this is part of what's
leading us to the very end
ojin also tells him something very
important
it's time for you to stop running
it's time for you to
face this thing and not just face it
to hunt it
ojn says um
do not transform yourself again the
shadow seeks to destroy your true being
no where you should go i do not know i
have an idea of what you should do but
it's a hard thing to say to you you must
turn around
if you go ahead if you keep running
wherever you run you will meet danger
and evil
it drives you it chooses the way you
will go you must choose you must seek
what seeks you you must hunt
the hunter
and so
this is going to be a turning point in
the story the next chapter is actually
called hunting chapter 8 and what we
find is that the shadow leads get into a
sort of trap
we find out that ged is is uh
going to go out and chase the shadow he
says on the sea he wished to meet it if
needed he must he was not sure why this
was yet he had a terror of meeting the
thing again on dry land out of the sea
there was storms and monsters but no
evil powers evil is of
earth and there is no see no running of
river or spring in the dark land we're
getting once gone death is the dry place
though the sea itself was a danger to
him in the hard weather of the season
the danger and change and instability
seemed to him a defense and choice and
when he met the shadow in the final end
of his folly he thought
maybe he could grip the thing even as it
gripped him and drag it down with the
weight of his body and the weight of his
own death down into the darkness of the
deep sea from which so held it might not
rise again so he's ready to risk his
life
to destroy
this evil that has been chasing him and
threatens earth sea he says once he gets
to
this this place the only aisle between
gant and narena
he says
uh come then come on what do you wait
for shadow i am here i get the sparrow
hawk and i summon my shadow and then the
shadow comes
he says it had been it had done with the
body of the australian ormond and not as
gabbath did it follow him nor did it
wear that beast shape in which he'd seen
it on rock noll and in his dreams it had
a shape now even in the daylight in its
pursuit of get in its struggle with him
on the moors it had drawn power from him
sucking it into himself and it may be
that his summoning of him had given it
to it or forced upon it some form or
semblance certainly it had now some
likeness to a man though being a shadow
it casts no shadow and what does he do
he struggles with it right he chases it
for he talks about hunted and hunter and
eventually he's drawn up and his ship is
is capsized in wrecks and
now you know he meets with these people
i'm going to skip ahead
he also runs into it
at another place right and
the shadow appears this is a little bit
later
in the boat
here we are
the shadow stood behind him in the boat
had he lost one instant he had been lost
but he was ready and lunged to seize and
hold the thing which wavered and
trembled there in arm's reach no
wizardry would serve him now but only
his own flesh his life itself against
the unliving he spoke no word but
attacked and the boat plunged and
pitched from his sudden turn and lunge a
pain ran up his arms into his breast
taking away his breath an icy cold
filled him he was blinded yet in his
hands it sees the shadow there was
nothing darkness air
and here he has an important realization
all terror was gone
all joy was gone
it was a chase no longer
he was neither hunted nor hunter now for
the third time they had met and touched
he had of his own will turned to the
shadow
seeking to hold it with living hands he
had not held it but he had forged
between them a bond a link that had no
breaking point there was no need to hunt
the thing down to track it nor would its
flight avail it
neither would escape when they had come
to the time and place for their last
meeting
they would meet so we've gone from ged
being the hunted
chased by the shadow trying to flee it
to turning around and becoming the
hunter
chasing it as it flees
and now
they're ready to have their final
confrontation which takes quite a while
two chapters worth and and the very end
of the book right
what we find is in the meantime the
shadow has taken on
ged's form we find that on one of the
islands just a day before
somebody like ged had been seen and when
ged runs into vetch vetch said i saw you
three days ago but you ignored me what's
up with that and god tells them about
the
shadow and then they go out to
chase this thing together and i'm going
to skip ahead to the final
confrontation
so
ged
takes them far out there to where the
land or where the sea
begins to turn into
land
and he steps out as the shadow
is approaching
at first it was shapeless but as it drew
nearer it took on the look of a man an
old man it seemed it seemed gray and
grim coming towards ged and now notice
the transformations it goes through
even as ged saw his father the smith in
that figure he saw it was not an old man
but a young man it was jasper
jasper's insolent handsome young face
and silver clasp grey cloak and stiff
stride hateful was the look he fixed on
ged across the dark intervening
heir and then it became pechavari a
person that ged had become friends with
earlier on in the work still god did not
stop and went forward
then
the thing that faced him changed utterly
spreading out to either side as if it
opened enormous thin wings it writhed
swelled and shrank again ged saw in it
for an instant skewers
white
there we go
face and a pair of clouded steering eyes
suddenly a fearful face he did not know
man or monster with writhing lips and
eyes that were like pits going into
black emptiness
then
what happens
ged spoke the shadow's name
and in the same moment the shadow spoke
without lips or tongue
saying the same word and the two voices
were one voice
what is the shadow's name
the shadow's name is his name
again
does this mean the shadow had always
been him all along laguna's not saying
that
but it has become bound to him
and what what results
it's over
he says um we find that that man
uh get it neither lost nor won
but naming the shadow of the death with
his own name had made himself whole now
that's an important line he'd
reintegrated himself
was the naming here naming in the sense
of having figured out its name and
calling it by that name
or should we see this as rather
get imposing
upon the shadow
his own name since the shadow lacks a
name giving to it his own name leguin
doesn't tell us both of those are
possible interpretations of what's
happening here
what is the result
gad had made himself whole
a man who knowing his whole true self
cannot be used or possessed by any power
other than himself and whose life
therefore is lived for life's sake and
never in the roo the service of ruin or
pain or hatred
or the dark
and that brings
this great early part of the saga of of
earthsea
to a close gad
again fleeing
facing
hunting and then finally
naming reciprocally
his shadow
you